aujourd'hui vous avez une police
municipale qui est en sous-effectif et
une collaboration insuffisant entre la
police nationale et la police municipale
de de levier pour nous la prévention
également la mise en place d'agents de
tranquillité publique dont le rôle sera
d'abord d'assurer une continuité du
service public or les chiffres de la
délinquance est un peu normal au pc
c'est vrai que la vidéo surveillance
fonctionnent bien par contre on a le
même modèle que dans toutes les villes
moyennes de france c'est la rue les deux
trafics divers etc
et ça c'est pas de notre ressort même si
on a une convention d'intervention assez
souvent avec la police avec la police
nationale
donc la sécurité ont fait je vais vous
dire ce que l'on peut il faut rétablir
la sécurité il faut doubler les
effectifs de la police municipale faut
engager un grand plan de sécurisation du
quotidien fonds engagés aussi un grand
plan de lutte contre le trafic de drogue
qui gangrènent c'est ces quartiers tout
ça c'est la priorité des priorités parce
qu'il n'y aura pas d'attractivité s'il
n'y a pas de sécurité sur la sécurité
elle même au sens où on l'entend
habituellement et qui sont un peu les
chevaux de bataille de monsieur au
doublé de madame fort ou ce qu'on
pensait qu'il faut mettre un terme la la
vidéoprotection au développement de la
vidéoprotection qui nous coûte des
postes de policiers sur le terrain et
c'est ça qui est efficace et qu'il faut
remettre aussi des éducateurs et offrir
des perspectives plus heureux aux jeunes
de la ville
si on veut qu'ils aillent vais dans la
bonne direction et qui ne serait ce pas
tenté par les sirènes des trafics et
autres problèmes